the most famous man you've never heard
of
author David Carlin discusses the life
and times of mr. rice a well-known
entertainer and humorist in America in
the 19th century this event is an hour
good evening and welcome to the
Larchmont library
I'm Nancy Donovan representing the
library and we're pleased to have you
here this evening to get to know David
Carr Lyon our author for the evening
David is a local resident he lives in
Larchmont and there's some interesting
things about his past
David graduated from the University of
California Berkeley and from the law
school there but at the same time he
decided to go to Clown College Ringling
Brothers camp Clown College
so he went off to Clown College even
though he was just about to pass the bar
he had taken the bar exam and was
waiting for the results so he spent
three years with Ringling Brothers
Barnum and Bailey Circus as one of their
clowns and then he went on came on here
to New York City and worked in the
theater here in New York for a few years
and went off to Northwestern where he
got a PhD in theater we're pleased to
have David who is the author of Dan Rice
the most famous man you never heard of
and we know you'll enjoy hearing from
David David Carr Lyon
thank you good evening thank you for
coming on a rainy evening a hundred and
fifty years ago somebody making their
way up the Boston Post Road from New
York to New Haven and on to Boston just
a few steps from the library right here
might have stopped when they stopped
there chatting with say a local resident
and if somebody mentioned Dan Rice
whoever that traveler was they would
know exactly who it was they would pass
around one of his jokes that may sing a
snatcher to one of his songs
that's 150 years ago a hundred years ago
about the time Dan Rice died and
Larchmont was becoming a burgeoning
summer film community there would be a
few of those theater and film veterans
here in Larchmont who would have
remembered the name but everybody else
totally blank and fifty years ago here
nobody and tonight 150 years later let's
see if I can do something about that I
wrote the book with three questions in
mind who is Dan rice why was he famous
why did he fall from Fame Dan rice to
begin with was the the answers to those
questions are not trivial moments for
historians they have to do with our
American past with how we formed as a
country through the 19th century Dan
rice was in the middle of that in the
same way that we see Shakespeare not
only in direct quotations and other
writers but in almost the genetic code
of writing of the way we look at writing
similarly Dan rice is a part of our
American culture unlike Shakespeare
though people know who he is and they
see those quotations they see those
influences
denne rice less so
and we'll talk about that tonight by job
description dan rice was a clown in a
circus but I must immediately stop take
a step back and explain that those mean
very different things now than they used
to a circus was not what it is now a
juvenile entertainment a place to take
kids kind of wait to pass the time when
you're looking for a little bit of
pleasure on an evening circus was a
place of pleasure but it was an adult
entertainment it was a place where a
talking clown like dan rice would stand
up there and talk about passing currents
talk about politics talk about what
women were wearing he at one point
talked about his preference for the
latest fashion and women's clothes he
called it the lo and behold style it was
this American circus in the 1850s 1860s
was a place of sex and violence Dan rice
in the middle of that stood there in the
ring talking about whatever came to mind
whatever was on people's minds and in
the process became a public figure
not simply famous but known throughout
the country for his opinions in our age
he might become one of the talking heads
on one of the radio show I was one of
the television shows and then from that
he became a political candidate later
ages would would diminish that and say
he was just doing it for publicity they
were legitimate campaigns for office and
he did them from the circus ring he
stood in the circus ring and ran for the
Pennsylvania State Senate then for
Congress and then for president to give
you some kind of cultural references he
was he piled around with Stephen Foster
he claimed connection with the Mormon
Joseph Smith in Joseph Smith's early
days on the western frontier that one
was not true he rice made many claims
but there was a slight connection in
that he did dine with Smith's Widow
after Joseph Smith was lynched by
anti-mormon mobs dan rice was reviewed
by Walt Whitman favorably he competed
against PT Barnum he feuded with the
famous tribute New York Tribune editor
Horace Greeley and most people said he
came off better in the deal his
influences continued denne rice toured
with Dan Rice's great show before Barnum
& Bailey used the phrase the greatest
show on earth Barnum and Bailey's press
agent at the time was Rice's cousin who
had been Rice's press agent he was the
great American humorist 20 toward
America's rivers and roads including
stops in Hannibal Missouri where a young
Sam Clemens lived few years later that
Sam Clemens as Mark Twain would write
Huckleberry Finn in which a circus fits
right into the middle of the book
discussing a circus clown Twain also
toured later as the American humorist
borrowing Rice's title and then now this
is a tough one the traditional take on
Dan Rice is that he was the model for
Uncle Sam
that's not exactly so because Uncle Sam
was an icon that was growing in various
versions over 50 60 70 years on the
other hand if you're talking about
somebody who dressed in stars and
stripes who had a goatee or a top hat if
you're talking about somebody who knew
the whole country and was known by the
whole country its Dan Rice and then just
to to kind of I wish we had I wish it I
wish with my slides I could do what they
could do in film and sort of blend into
each other if we go back here now this
is Dan Rice at is funkiest
but it's also what he would look like in
the ring at times sometimes he would
dress in the custom we expect of a 19th
century clown the stars the stripes the
top hat but some looks wrong way but
sometimes in evening wear in what proper
middle-class gentlemen would wear still
as a clown in the circus ring he would
alternate he would do it differently
depending on the audience upon the town
how he was feeling that day what he was
running for office or not but now
imagine this suit with stripes and
you've got the Uncle Sam icon so that's
a brief version of the who of Dan rice
but why was he famous I suppose that the
first thing that I have to say is his
talent he was incredibly smart he was a
very funny man he had gone through an
apprenticeship dancing and singing in
the stables America was a dancing
singing kind of place Stephen Foster's
biographers talk about how the foster
family in Pittsburgh who were growing up
with Dan rice as a young man would
serenade each other they'd gather in the
parlor and sing they'd go out on the
town Carosi and sing they'd go to a
woman's house and sing under her window
they were singing and dancing that was
Dan Rice then he went out with a learnin
pig he had a trained Pig now I don't
want to give away too many trains trade
secrets pigs can't do too many things
however if you frame it right if you
suggest what the pig is doing then
suddenly those few things a pig can do
grunt paw walk amble become a whole
universe of things so that the same Pig
doing exactly the same thing pawing on
the ground can be
adding so similar can you can you add
two three I'm sorry three plus two and
so he would signal the pig it would par
five times and it's a mathematical
genius
if you put down a Y or an N and say is
this the smartest audience you had this
season it always pays to a flatter the
audience the pig would go over and paw
on the Y depending how on however I
signaled it then he became a song man
and then in 1843 his first circus he was
a comic singer and then a clown I
mentioned earlier that circus is very
different now than it was then clown is
very different clown was being defined
at the time it was still not quite clear
what clown meant because there were the
silent clowns that were knockabout
clowns who did what we would now
consider acrobatic clowning there were
talking clowns like Rice who sometimes
specialized in Shakespeare they would be
Shakespearean clowns
now that could range the gamut from a
kind of bastardized quotation to a whole
soliloquy rice had a hundred and four
line rhymed verse version of Othello
which he claimed the authorship he
didn't write it but it was his in the
same way that singers now have their
signature songs also he was in the same
circus at the same time rather at
different times in the same show he
would do white face clowning and black
face clowning minstrel see white men
blacking up as black men were a standard
part of the antebellum the pre Civil War
amusements Dan rice would do that kind
of thing as a matter of fact the first
thing we have in his handwriting is a
letter to Stephen Foster's brother where
he says I'm making $25 a week which was
probably a lie in blackface and
white-faced clowning
the the other thing that really helped
propel rice to fame was an incredible
talent his words came like a waterfall
they were well let let's mix metaphors
all over the place like a waterfall
sparking off everything bouncing off the
walls his words were like a kaleidoscope
think Robin Williams if you if you ever
see Robin Williams in concert he will
talk in a space of maybe three minutes
about ten different subjects you never
notice when he's shifting and you're
laughing the whole time that's Dan Rice
Dan Rice also physically was stocky and
powerful like Robin Williams I mentioned
Robin Williams because he was then I had
in mind as I was writing that's my model
of Uncle Sam a rather of Dan Rice race
was also famous because he had
incredible animal acts
now he had a waltzing camel again don't
want to give away too many trade secrets
waltzing camel meant that the band would
play a walls while the trainer would
walk the camel around the ring and if
they changed the music to a givat than
it was a camel to condense that a givat
and they would do it in time to the
animal but there would be those reviews
talking about these wonderful musical
animals who could dance in time to the
music
he had comic mules he had a rhino
reputed to be the first trained Rhino in
two thousand years I found anything to
the contrary there's there's a great
Rhino guy and that's especially he's a
lawyer in Atlanta and he just
specializes and rhinoceroses they
weren't called rhinos at the time by the
way Rhino at the time was slang for
money but I I don't think a rhino could
do much probably a lot less than a pig
but it was trained and he had llama ruk
his
rope walking elephant now I'll let you
in on a little secret this is a big
controversy in the animal training world
because well rather I'm gonna make it a
controversy the animal trainers I know I
used to be with Ringling Brothers and
Barnum and Bailey Circus so I've got a
few contacts the animal trainers I know
say it can't be done
the Fred Dollinger at Circus World
Museum in Baraboo Wisconsin was
originally an engineer and is now the
curator and he says it can't be done
because physically day after day in a
summer tent you couldn't set up that
rigging and then get an animal walk an
elephant walking on that I mean just
couldn't be done so between the elephant
trainers and the engineers they say it
couldn't be done in my book I say it
happened and I'll tell you why Dan rice
was immensely popular partly because of
that popularity he was also regularly
criticized there was a whole fight going
on about the issue of popularity some
people criticized him because he was
popular and talking about politics in
the ring so over the years that he had
Lalla ruk in all of the criticisms
directed at him and there were some gym
dandies now one word suggested that this
didn't happen nobody said the tightrope
walking elephant is a humbug that's
evidence as far as I'm concerned I may
have to duke it out with buckles
Woodcock famous animal trainer
I mean elephant trainer because he said
it can't be done but nobody complained
about it nobody and they complained
about everything else
they said the showgirls are ugly they
said Dan Rice has no wit and he's vulgar
besides they said the the Rhino is a
humbug it just sits there which it
probably did but nobody ever said
anything I could find that the elephant
didn't walk the tightrope so
those are the sides I did
point/counterpoint with you and you can
decide what you want now he also dan
rice was also famous because he was king
of the circus at a time when circus was
deeply embedded in American life I
alluded to that earlier but okay now
when we think of the good old days of
the circus
you can conjure the image of what the
summer Circus was like in the 1850s that
is you're in rural town you've had maybe
two visitors in the past six months the
only color in your life is the green on
the trees and a few wildflowers and some
berries cuz the houses are brown the
ground is brown your faces are brown
your clothes are brown
it's dull and drab and it's a hard life
now the circus comes to town with red
and yellow and blue and green and colors
with all those colors with lights I mean
you at night you are to your shed with
the candle or maybe an oil lamp if you
can afford it the circus comes and
you've got a big spoke with hundred
candles on it all let so you got light
in the middle of the night
you also have let me see do I have this
set up right
girls and boys you've got men and women
showing off their legs and the whole
culture was aware of it now you often
didn't talk about it directly but
everybody knew when you went to the
circus you were gonna get to see you're
gonna get to see what the had men's legs
and women's legs as a matter of fact now
this this picture is from a book a
sensationalist book from about thirty
years later the 1880s there's another
picture called playing circus playing
circus on down the road became slang for
obscene games with prostitutes but for
now it was legs and bodies torsos tight
clothes that you just didn't see in my
perkins at church now so you had you had
that summer excitement and you had all
of this and the clown on the other hand
the circus as I say was deeply embedded
in American life it was only in the
summer that you toured with those tents
out in the boondocks in the winter the
Stars went to the cities
it was urban sophistication it was a
feature of cities so you would have
circuses competing with theaters
competing in theaters themselves this
particular one Dan Rice's amphitheater
built for him in New Orleans one of the
major cities of the time it later became
the Academy of Music which through the
late 19th century was the jewel of New
Orleans theaters it was built originally
for rice to come and do a circus in the
winter you had the same thing at the
Baltimore at Front Street you had it in
New York theaters Boston theaters
Pittsburgh and Cincinnati though they
were slightly smaller you had it at the
Walnut Street Theatre in Philadelphia
which I mentioned B for two reasons
especially because the Walnut Street
Theatre in Philadelphia is still
standing
and still presenting performances and
because when I was an actor I performed
there too in and I played the same house
so you had you had urban sophistication
you had that excitement in the summers
and you had sex and violence which are
kind of those those representatives for
life and death kind of our symbols on
why we choose to look at the the more
interesting parts sex and violence but
that's what behind it now so here's
here's the implication of sex by the way
it's not just that you could see there
was also the suggestion that you could
get easy sex that these were people with
loose morals men and women maybe it's
true I heard it about the circus so as I
was when I was on the circus so you had
the sex but you also had the violence
now when a circus came to town in the
old days that is the old old days say
1848 1850 to 1856 and you rolled into a
little town in Illinois or I or upstate
New York for the fighters in town
it's fresh meat it's somebody new to
fight a circus had to be an efficient
fighting unit because almost every town
you're going to get in a fight as a
matter of fact you you pretty much had
to hire your hands to be good fighters
dan rice wrote a diary I found a diary
of his from 1856 when he was touring
Massachusetts he noted when there
weren't fights in Salem and Lynn
Massachusetts fighting was so common
hudson river towns college towns were
special fighting towns he circus history
particularly mentioned Princeton Yale
and
the University of Michigan my alma mater
I suppose college boys wanted to prove
that they were as tough as anybody
mining towns and river towns the Hudson
River lots of fights lots of fights as a
matter of fact one got rice in a lot of
trouble up in Troy New York which I
mentioned because the one circus fight I
got in when I was on the circus was in
Troy New York and I was the only one I
cannot came out with any injuries which
which shows you that don't fight unless
you're good at it I'm not I didn't
intend to I just sort of wanted to watch
but so but it was more so races Fame was
more than his talent and it was more
than circuses central place in American
culture rice insinuated himself into the
deepest feelings of American life it was
a very volatile time there were
bankruptcies galore as capitalism's
started to take hold in the United
States as industrialism started to take
hold and you had industrial towns you
had that kind of increasing
regimentation there were bankruptcies
there were failures I mean the free you
can say what you want about the free
market but without any protections at
all
lots of people fail Dan Rice failed all
the time he was a kind of symbol that
you could fail and come back again
because he kept doing it he feuded all
the time he was usually in a fight
himself I say in my book that if he had
not been in circus history for being in
for being a great clown he would have
been in circus history for being
probably one of the best fighters of
American circus he got into it all the
time and he got infused former owners
former employers there was one famous
fight he had up and down the Mississippi
so it spoke to the anxiety of American
people the brave front front we can do
whatever II want head to a certain
extent that worry that was behind it and
it was lurking all the time you could
never tell I mean remember the the more
prominent history ulysses s grant was a
failure most of the
life Abraham Lincoln went into debt that
was part of the American history that
was part of the American story Dan Rice
was there and Dan rice was there saying
I can survive he named one of the
circuses of the Phoenix Phoenix circus I
can rise from the ashes
there was also now this is need to warm
up for this okay hang tight for this the
middle class was forming that is in
earlier days you really didn't have what
we now consider middle managers white
collar you had manual laborers and you
had the elite the founding fathers were
an elite the owners that kind of thing
as as the 19th century developed you had
people who were in between well the in
between is always a difficult place to
be
so as the middle class formed it wasn't
quite sure what it was apparently
because the United States doesn't really
acknowledge that there are classes so it
could distinguish itself from the elite
by saying what we've got more common
sense than they do you know I got more
common sense in my little finger than
you know name your elite or they may be
rich but they're not happy okay
or they may be smart but do they really
know anything about life okay so we can
dismiss the elite fairly easily but what
about those who are doing what we used
to do day labor you can't say they're
lower class that's rude so the middle
class developed a way to kind of
identify itself a kind of mutual
identification and admiration society
that pushed itself away from a place it
wasn't that far truth remember if you
failed you're a day laborer again so
what it did was develop strategies that
we're still using for instance which
fork to use movies still do that with
the innocent character the it you either
show somebody is not very smart by not
being aware of sophistication but more
often it's an innocent
like figure like Tom Hanks in the movie
big where he goes to the fancy schmancy
cocktail party and he's a child who's
grown to a man's body so he's our
innocent we identify with him and he
doesn't know what to do so somehow we're
watching the movie and what he does is
exactly right
now it so the middle class was doing
that with the proper way to greet people
the proper clothes to wear and when how
to behave at performances for instance
the idea that we applaud at the end of a
symphony rather than between movements
is there anything inherent about that
anything natural there was a critic in
Boston in the 1880s who said who with
german ideas said you it's a whole piece
of art and you must wait to the end to
applaud so in jazz now when they do the
the solo we applaud but if we really
like what they did after the first
movement we sit quietly because we know
our role the middle class was learning
to be quiet and the the motto the thing
that really clinched for everybody was
aspiration we aspire to something higher
what does that mean they didn't know
neither do we
it was just a way to signal I'm with you
we all aspire to something higher higher
than what than those other people who
are those other people won't be kind of
rude to name them but they're not our
kind of people
I mean there are all kinds of language
now I seem to be coming for our field
from Dan Rice except let me get back to
rice rice was the head of this cultural
parade everything about his circus he
denominated as an aspirational thing he
too would take the crude vulgar jokes of
the clown and improved them refine them
he too would take a vulgar circus and
refine it and make it aspirational so
you had his wasn't a circus but Dan
Rice's great show
circus dropped out of his advertisements
clown dropped out of his advertisements
he was America's the great American
humorist let me see if I've got his
horse excelsior okay we're in New York
what's the New York state motto
excelsior what does excelsior mean
higher longfellows famous poem excelsior
I learned it first through rocky and
bullwinkle on TV that was the cartoon of
Rocky and Bullwinkle and the guy
climbing the mountain he knows now why
he climbs but he climbs excelsior the
strange device he he carries Longfellow
wrote a poem explaining what the poem
meant and what he explained was his hero
aspires to something higher what higher
just something higher so here you had
the animal that was named something
higher its entrance into the arena was
on the shoulders of the workers of the
circus but rice usually advertised it as
gentleman of the town and it also had an
act the the horse did where it would
climb stairs now probably not that high
in this picture they took liberties but
it literally climbed to something higher
it was Excelsior and of course at the
core of aspiration was the hearth the
wife the mother teaching values to the
children now that would have been news
to the 18th century because women
historically have been Eve the one who
offers temptation the 19th century took
some ideas from other sources and
decided that that that did glorify women
the Virgin Mary is a prominent example
but taking it out of its religious
context the middle class in the 19th
century brought it into the home and
said ok the man will go out and fight
for the daily bread and to go as close
to the line as he can without
necessarily cheating without necessarily
lying on the other hand like the movie
Godfather we won't talk about some of
those things we do the wife will not
know about that why because she's at
home with the children protecting the
sanctity of the American family the wife
is presumed now to be the mother
especially as presume
to be more noble more moral than the man
because the man is out there in that
battle for survival so this is Maggie
Dan Rice his first wife he he married
strong women she I'm not sure if I can
do this rape
this was after they divorced she went
out with mrs. Dan Rice's great show
at one point he sued because she was
using Dan Rice's great show so she
couldn't she had to stop using that so
this was an ad from 1863 after they
divorced so that's Maggie and she was
and the advertisement that said he
wasn't a clown but great American
humorist now started to talk about her
as the moral center of the circus and
she performed because to display
yourself in public is kind of rude if
you're really if you're really a shy
modest person woman then you're at home
you're not out on the streets displaying
yourself much less in a circus ring so
why was she in a circus ring to educate
the apprentices so she had an
intellectual function and she was
educating the women of society who would
come to watch in healthful exercise so
that they would have the rosy glow on
their cheek without the use of makeup
painted women used makeup but if you had
good exercises as a woman you've got
proper exercise so she was instructing
the women of America that's why she was
in the circus that's why she was
performing and Dan Rice himself not only
the great American humorist but a
gentleman jester a public figure this
bust was done by the same man who did
the bust of Stephen Douglas
Stephen Douglas was the person Dan rice
supported in his races against Abraham
Lincoln in 1858 for Senate and in 1864
President
so Dan rice was famous because of his
talent his great comic genius because of
how deeply embedded circus was and
performance generally was in American
life and because he fit this growing
tide of how the middle-class wanted ICI
itself so why do you fall from thing
well the the usual story of a fall from
theme of the of the merely popular is
that they're popular and inherently
shallow so of course they're gonna fall
from Fame whatever happened to stories
come up all the time I mean has Britney
Spears overtaken Madonna I don't know
but if she has then there'll be those Oh
Madonna yes she was popular for a while
but then she faded and then Britney
Spears Oh she'll fade and we expect that
of popularity dan Rice's is a more
interesting and more complex story and
there are two overlapping reasons he
fell from theme the first was his Civil
War politics he went into the Civil War
those years leading up to the Civil War
that started in 1861 arguing about the
fanatics who were trying to destroy the
country in later years he and his
apologists would suggest that the
fanatics trying to destroy the country
were the Southerners who were trying to
secede that's not who he was talking
about he was talking about the
abolitionists they were in in retrospect
we have come to honor them as well we
should I can't think of a reform more
necessary for the United States than
abolition I mean that's America's great
sin with slavery on the other hand the
Constitution allowed slavery it
acknowledged it and allowed it so when
the abolitionist said our country is
rotten and deserves to be destroyed if
the South wants to go let them most of
the country thought they were crackpots
they would have Constitution burning
parties the way people now are up in
arms about flag burning they would burn
the Constitution and say this is a
rotten document so going into the Civil
War Rice was in effect taking the
Democratic position there were problems
with that especially as the war started
to turn and as Abraham Lincoln one of my
heroes transformed what had been simply
a civil war into a fight for freedom
Abraham Lincoln said in the Gettysburg
Address and I'm taking this from a
wonderful book by Gary Wells a wonderful
argument four score and seven years ago
in the Gettysburg Address four score and
seven years ago back wasn't it the
Constitution it was the Declaration of
Independence that was a political
document when when Abraham Lincoln stood
up in Gettysburg and said four score and
seven years ago he was saying our
country was founded by the people of the
people by the people for the people how
he ended the Gettysburg Address he was
saying that the people and the United
States and that the Constitution is a
discussion of that a second draft so it
was the people who formed it and States
can't leave and if this fight is about
anything if this carnage is about
anything it's about not just keeping the
country together but a new birth of
freedom all men and as we learn since
all people are created equal the
Democrats including rice going around
the country arguing in the circus ring
running for the state Senate and
Pennsylvania was saying of the states by
the states for the states that was the
piece Democrat position so he was
arguing against Lincoln against the
Republicans and especially against the
abolitionists it didn't work he was
wrong the Democrats were wrong the South
was wrong they were talking about
original intent the way we're talking
about original intent now but slavery
was wrong
Lincoln had the genius to know that and
a legal way
worked the country around and lead the
country where it didn't even know wanted
to go if you had said in 1861 yeah we're
gonna go fight at Bull Run and it's
about it's to free the slaves the North
would have said now most of those
soldiers would have left the field they
had to work their way through it led
step by patient step by lincoln Rice was
resisting and rice had the law behind
the Constitution said slavery is all
right so he had a lot of trouble with
that after his divorce from Maggie he in
effect got a trophy one trophy wife this
is Rebecca she was the young daughter of
the local society in Garrard
Pennsylvania where he had set up winter
quarters they didn't like much Marion
there the flower of their arrest
aristocracy to Dan Rice but this is her
with excelsior jr. the original
Excelsior died this was another white
horse blind did the same tricks so
that's Rebecca and there were comments
when he married saying well he's trying
to get himself right on the Union
question by forming a union with his new
wife by the way lest you think too badly
of Dan for taking a trophy wife Maggie
took a trophy husband
she married their young treasurer and
actually his name's up here somewhere
but she was in charge so through the
Civil War and out of the Civil War Dan
rice developed a few strategies to
distance himself from what had been
southern sympathies in 1865 he
commissioned and paid for what was said
to be the first monument to the Civil
War dead in Garrard Pennsylvania's
hometown again the local a some of the
locals didn't like it the aristocracy of
the small town so they tried to halt him
from doing this particularly because
that's his house back there he put it in
a square right in front of his house
they thought that was a little showing
but it became a national event it made
the front cover of Harper's Weekly
National Journal reporters came from
Cleveland from New York from
Philadelphia thousands came and of
course he made hay while the Sun shone
he had three shows that day instead of
his usual two so he paid for the
monument he started to create fictions
now the biggest one is probably one of
the most important ones to know about
that he was best friends with Abraham
Lincoln if you've ever read anything
about Dan Rice because there's a little
bit out there and tell my book what you
read is that Dan Rice was best friends
with Abraham Lincoln he'd come to the
White House and tell him the mood of the
country they swapped dirty jokes they
talked about the old days and the
western plains not not Lincoln's
historians have found and there are
their their name is legion they found
nothing there's there's a book Lincoln
day by day
that nothing about Dan rice there's
nothing in primary documentation of Dan
rice visiting Lincoln a one biographer
of rice said that he went to visit
Lincoln when he played Washington and he
played Washington during the Civil War
he said rice went to visit Lincoln but
the newspapers didn't report it because
of the gravity of the Civil War they
reported the battles but they didn't
report this alleged visit but but more
importantly than that like not more
importantly but equally with that lack
of evidence is the fact that he was a
political opponent he was traveling the
country saying Lincoln is destroying the
country now Lincoln had an expensive
heart he had a huge soul he could stand
with people who attacked him all the
time because he had his eye on a greater
goal so he might have met Dan rice he
might have stood there next to him but
no evidence of it and there were
political opponents definitely not best
friends which is a shame because it's a
great story particularly if you're in
circus you
that one as a matter of fact that's how
I got interested in the first place I
was out of the circus myself I'd left
the circus I was an actor in New York
City a friend of mine in we were
backstage we were touring city parks and
some time on her hands and he told me
about this circus clown had been best
friends with Abraham Lincoln and I
thought I was a circus clown
I think Abraham Lincoln this great guy
this sounds cool and by the time I found
out it was wrong I was hooked
so I said there were two overlapping
reasons rice fell from Fame first his
Civil War politics now he told these
stories that kept getting him away from
what had been his his actual beliefs but
enough of the people knew where he had
been that they could dismiss it they
could ignore it but they wouldn't forget
it then he was starting to become simply
a politician evading what had been his
earlier stand that makes for tenuous
popularity but there was another reason
and if you could divorce one or these
other reasons I don't know what would
have happened to rice I mean it's
possible taking doing the what-if game
ballet had been considered a vulgar form
because that was nothing but women
showing off their legs so I mean the
circus at least had other things going
on but ballet ballet girls basically
which if you were to say is stripper now
that's that was what ballet girls were
considered well ballet somehow as as
this hierarchy of performance forms
developed some became considered high
symphony Shakespeare ballet now my
personal opinion has nothing to do with
the book is that there are no words in
ballet they're no words in symphony so
you can put up whatever meaning you want
on it
I'll just throw that one in for free but
Dan Rice was saying mine is an elevated
form too so perhaps without the civil
war and this other reason I'm about to
talk about
he might have pushed his up as well
it's a what-if game but there was this
double whammy these two reasons his
Civil War opinions and the other one was
culture was changing now Dan rice rode
that wave as the middle class was
forming and it said we want more
elevated forms we want to aspire to
something higher and we want our the
things we go seek to aspire to something
higher as well well Dan rice filled that
bill but there was another way of coming
that billowed out of the first one and
that was if you have some things high
some things have to be low notice how
often when you're talking with your
friends when you're reading the paper
and it talks about something that's
artistic notice how often it contrasts
it to something else that's not well
this isn't mere entertainment how often
have you heard that it's embedded in the
way we now think about performance and
that was forming in the 19th century so
Dan rice wanted to go up Lots people
thought he was going up but you need
something low well what fills the low
bill better than the circus where you
got women showing off their legs or
you've got animals with all of their
sweat and grunts and defecation right
there in front of you you've got clowns
some of them with vulgar jokes so
audience audiences were starting to look
at that way also another key change in
the 1840s and 1850s audiences at
performances and politics were
participatory they consider themselves
patrons of the event you didn't go to
the theater in 1840 1845 to sit there in
quiet in the dark and appreciate the art
in front of you you went up there to get
involved if you liked a monologue you'd
yell so they'd repeat the monologue and
they would and circus if Dan Royce was
talking about politics people were
talking back well audiences were
learning new behavior what an audience
does is sit quietly and watch the art
framed like a picture at a museum so
technology helped that because with the
original technology those candles up
there everybody's equally lit you went
to the theater to be seen as much as
anything you'd sit there you'd roam
around the theater you'd talk you'd talk
to the actors you'd talk to the clowns
well lights went down and audiences we
all learned our place which was to sit
quietly and observe Dan Rice's strength
had been in that robust interaction with
him right there on the ramparts as it
were right there to the people with them
talking back that simply doesn't work
with this new quiet decorum now we can
talk about all the 20th 20th century
manifestations where they've tried to
recreate that excitement in various ways
audience participation
theater-in-the-round various forms but
they're all working off the basic model
that the best way to do it is a quiet
audience that was a model that was being
formed partly by Dan Rice ironically he
was he was hoisted on his own petard he
was wrecked by the things he had helped
put in motion so he became a drunk he
became a bankrupt for good almost for
good Girard Pennsylvania where he had
set up his winter quarters wanted
nothing to do with him he divorced or
rather his wife divorced him but then he
pulled himself up he was nothing if not
resilient and he went on a lecture tour
of Texas in the 1880s and while he was
there he meant I think my favorite of
his three wives
Marcia Marcella great house
Robinson diga Fredo rice she was married
a bunch of times her father had been one
of the early cowboy pioneers forming the
the cattle ranches her husband captain
great house had been one of the first to
take cattle up to Dodge City he died on
the trail she became rich in Land and
Cattle it's not clear how rich she was
in money
then she married a couple others want to
ran off with her money she got back and
divorced him a dentist who was kind of
weakling and he died and and his family
blamed her she would write around San
Antonio in her buggy she tried to Elbert
elbow her way into the all-male
livestock Association of San Antonio
well you got two spirited people they
met and they married her family didn't
like it at all but they got married
that's Marcella and then he did a
lecture tour
he's so snake-oil Jo he's magic medicine
that's good for what ails you a plot you
can take it orally or apply it topic
topically it for cures blindness it
cures dropsy it cures almost anything
and then the last attempt for rice the
circus was changing it had been
relegated to low so the circus became
what we think of it now this kind of
marginal form for the kiddies
and a clown is good for the kids
very few people now go to the circus
adults go to the circus genuinely
expecting to laugh that was one of the
things I found when I was a clown so if
I ever did something that was really
funny I could tell by the surprise on
their faces that was my favorite
reaction actually I would be doing
something with the kids because people
bring their kids I'd be doing something
with the kids and then I could see out
of the corner of my eye
this white dawning in their eye because
it been glazed over either that's cute
there with the kids oh the clowns would
to get that's fine that's right and then
I'd see Oh what do you say oh so Dan
rice tried to latch on to this nostalgia
this sentimentality about circus so he
came back as old Uncle Dan not quite
coincidentally the Santa Claus figure
was growing through the same period from
a from a lean kind of treat or coal
giving kind of guy into the roly-poly
figure we think of now
good old Santa good ol uncle rice PT
Barnum competed with Dan Rice probably
one of the biggest biggest humbugs the
United States is known by the end of his
career he was Oh Phineas who just loved
children he kept posing with kids around
him he was just old uncle Phineas as
sweet and as innocent as you could like
john d rockefeller one of our robber
barons the end of his life kids around
him you know he just loved those little
kids dan rice tried to do the same thing
dan rice old-time circus songster and
then but he became virtually unknown he
had his first circus was 1843 in 1891 he
tried again here in New York tintblue
down which often happened he got sick
the circus died his circus died by then
they were all big ones anyway
he went to live with his mother's people
down in West Long Branch New Jersey and
Maggie his first wife came back to
nursing and then he died 1900 with
headed into not only a completely new
century but the circus totally changed
and now that by the 1880s we would
recognize the circus it is still mostly
what it was then and the ones that try
to be different circus all a Big Apple
Circus are still often working off that
model consider when you when you read
about one of the other new circuses
notice how often they say something like
but we are not Ringling sometimes by
name and sometimes saying we're not one
of those big extravaganzas well
Ringling's the big extravaganza now in
circuses there there are other circuses
out there three-ring circus but Ringling
it's the big one so if they say we're
not those big extravaganzas what they're
saying is what we're circus we're sort
of like them we do the same kinds of
stuff but we're not them we are got
better lighting in the case of Cirque du
Soleil big apple we're small and
intimate my wife my wife my own wife
says she likes that one ring better
because you can poke
better should have had some kind of
discussion about that before we got
married
so that's Dan rice let me see oh I
brought these up here they're you'd seen
the slide of that one Oh Uncle Dan or
rather Uncle Sam Dan this is a poster on
original from 1858 doesn't say circus
anywhere on this doesn't say clown it's
Dan Rice who will be talking about
events of the day and I made a little
bit of this in the book it's circus acts
and then it's also a huge spectacle
with the volcano with the appearance of
flowing lava
there's flowing water on stage there's
fire on stage and now remember this
isn't computer-generated stuff in fire
safety theaters these are old wooden
theaters this Swan is in New York City
Oh fiddlesticks I forget where it was oh
no oh no it's at the National Theater in
on Walnut Street in Philadelphia and the
name of this particular spectacle is the
magic ring now I'm not narium on the
other hand vogner was writing his magic
ring about this time and Dan Rice had
the same magic ring and the search and
the trolls in the mountain and the
princess well fagor had a princess but
the heroine and a secret kind of
character that was all on stage that was
what people went to the circus to see so
that oh I'm sorry I said 1858 1860 I'm
historian you know right now 1858 or
1860 doesn't matter a whole lot to you
but I know the difference so that was
1860 so I am now open for any questions
about anything ballet
George Balanchine whatever
well that's what I was going to ask I
was going to ask but ever happened with
his law degree all of this about Dan
racing you want to know about my law
degree well yeah my mother somebody said
in the audience
I graduated from vult all the University
of California Berkeley in 1976 while I
was waiting to take the bar exam I
applied to Clown College Ringling
Brothers and Barnum and Bailey Circus
Clown College
I took the bar exam then while I was
waiting to hear if I passed I found out
I had gotten into the Clown College so I
went to the clown College which was a
10-week program you don't learn to be
clown in ten weeks you need an audience
and I'll get back to the law school I
promise you when I first started writing
I thought I had nothing in common with
Dan Rice the circus was so totally
different it was a star I was not a star
I was one of the cavorting masses he was
a talking clown and though I talked a
lot when I went up in the seats
officially I was down in the rings and
doing pantomime kinds of things I was
just physical stuff so I thought there
were huge differences but I began to
realize as I worked on it that rice's
strength was that interaction with the
audience and the thing I learned in the
circus
especially when I went up into the seats
was interaction there are clowns who
like to clown in effect behind a
proscenium that is they like like the
idea that there is this gap I'd like to
go up there climbing on the seats
literally climbing on the seats and I
realized that the struggles I went
through were similar to the struggles
Dan Rice went through I'm not trying to
compare us he was infinitely greater
than I was but we took the same path so
back to law school I promised I'd get
back to it so I went to clown school and
a lot of people out of law school they
you know Goku's the South Pacific or
they go backpacking in Europe or they do
something for a wild
to break before they go off and and and
become lawyers and I figured that's what
clown school would be but then my father
surprised me at the graduation now I
didn't go to my own compensation neither
did my family and this is the
hippie-dippie sixties and I and I was
out in California for my law school
graduation so they hadn't come to that
long ways away and it wasn't that big a
deal my sister lived out there she came
but that's it
but clown school my father surprised me
flew down that night now the clown
college graduation is was clown school
is now defunct the the Ringling has
stopped sponsoring it but it is three
and a half four our performance that's
also a graduation ceremony
that's also an audition for the circus
lots of pressure but while everybody
else was worrying oh I hope I get us
contract oh I've wanted forever I wanted
to be a clown I was going oh what should
I do if I get a contract my father came
down and I said in effect you know I
really should go back to to the law and
he said why
and you know sometimes it's just that
look a thing oh yeah why so but I
figured I would do it for one year but
then at the end of the one year
ringling has has a two-year tour in
effect they go to some cities one year
and then that unit goes to other cities
while the second unit goes to the ones
the first one went to the year before
they alternate so I figured the end of
my first year well I'll get the full two
years okay cuz hadn't been to the west
coast yet funny I hadn't played Madison
Square Garden yet so I'd stay two years
and then they asked me to stay for a
third year to become their advanced
clown ambassador I had business cards
and everything I proceeded the circus by
week to do whatever publicity they had
I've got the key to the city of Cedar
Rapids Iowa I did a birthday I mean I
did a 4th of July picnic with the
governor of Texas I performed at
minor-league baseball games at North
Carolina basketball State basketball
game / wrestling at the Atlanta Omni my
toughest one one of my toughest ones
hockey at the Boston Gardens they don't
want to see a clown but I survived
hospital visits talks school visits
seminars at colleges my key to the city
of Cedar Rapids Iowa so I did that / 3rd
year and then I thought okay probably
time to go back to law that's what you
want to know one I didn't came to New
York to be an actor just some people you
just can't make anything out of no I was
an actor in New York primarily
Shakespeare I discovered that the acting
lessons of a clown I'll use some actor
jargon here being in the moment really
dealing with what happens rather than
memorizing your lines and doing whatever
you're going to do but really reacting
off of what people are doing and saying
there's a good acting lessons I learned
that as a clown so it helped me a lot
with I did some contemporary stuff a few
musicals which was probably mistake by
the casting director I love musicals but
my voice my voice I love musicals
I met my wife at an audition she's got a
great voice but then she went back to
school got her degree we decided we've
had enough of New York and trying to
make a living for now her with her
startup musicals me with my Shakespeare
Shakespeare doesn't pay a lot um though
it's great fun I loved I loved
Shakespeare so I went to Northwestern to
get my PhD we had kids I taught at the
University of michigan-flint and then we
decided you know New York is really
where we should be so we came back and
Here I am hoping to talk about Dan Rice
no oh that was your question
am i acting here now no no I'm not I did
after I got back sure that acting was
behind me get offered a part the actor's
dream a producer called me out of the
blue and said do you want to play Rip
Van Winkle I said sure that's a tough
one to pass up so but no no not acting
I'm writing this book and now trying to
decide what I'm gonna do next
maybe med school law no I've done that I
was I was the first I might my claim to
fame as a lawyer as sort of lawyer while
I was a student I was an intern at the
US Attorney's Office in Philadelphia and
they had recently changed their rules of
practice so I was I was told I'm not
gonna fight anybody about this I was
told I was the first student that is non
lawyer to represent the Eastern District
of Pennsylvania in federal court and I
won - yes another question
yeah what god mr. rice started in show
business what God Dan started in show
business
no no law school no law school it
claimed his father had been a law clerk
of Aaron Burr but he claimed lots of
things he did I mentioned that dancing
and singing in the stables that it was a
dancing singing country the dancing
singing fighting country he worked in
the stables
was good with horses drove wagons
probably some pickup horse races and in
the stables you danced and sang you'd go
to the theater and the next day like
teenage kids in the 50s and 60s you'd
watch Soul Train American Bandstand and
go home and practice they'd come to the
stables and they do whatever dances they
saw they'd sing the songs they heard and
he discovered he had a talent for it and
he had a strong ambition so he knew he
wanted to do more so when he had a
chance to go out with a learnin pig
remember the learnin pig he grabbed it
there is a suggestion that he didn't
even get paid that it was just room and
keep and maybe not even room but a
chance to get a foot in and I suspect
that was it his ambition and his talent
yes ma'am
we got it we got off microphone door
during the Civil War I know you
mentioned his political politics to what
extent was there also the circuses going
out and doing their thing during the
wartime mostly the circuses did what
you'd expect of performance now they
were if they were traveling in the north
because the south was cut off the south
was great place for touring circuses
well that was obviously cut off during
the North so lots of circuses in the
Northeast bumping up against each other
a lot went up into Canada some went on
international tours they went to South
America they went to the Sandwich
Islands Hawaii and for the most part
they waved the flag waved the flag are
li and fervently and wrap themselves in
the flag I've got I've got another
illustration in my book where Dan rice
is dressed in this style of outfit only
it's blue up here with stars and red and
white stripes all the way down
he literal and in one case he literally
wrapped himself in the flag because
there was some booze in Philadelphia
because of his southern sympathies so
for the most part of very Pro North Pro
Union especially as the war started to
turn in the late 1864 1865 as it started
to turn toward the north but I mean
there was still strong pockets of
Democratic feeling I mean New York City
had draft riots those folks said this
isn't our fight we're not going to go
fight they had writing about it you
could probably do a circus in New York
and at the time and have said I'm not so
sure if this was a good thing or words
to that effect but for all of the other
talking clowns few were as political as
rice and none were as ardently political
as rice so he was an exception in many
ways yes you had your hand up
okay what did you get your PhD in
theater history drama it was it was on
Dan rice now here's my comment I
remember many years ago Alan Alda was
asked how did you decide what to do and
he said I couldn't decide what I wanted
abby's I decided to be an actor I could
do everything yep yeah you an actor you
play lots of parts actually the part of
the appeal of being a lawyer is that
there is the possibility that you can be
a specialist in lots of different things
because whatever case you're working on
you become a bestest specialist and the
science of technic computer technology
in human relations I mean there there is
that prospect and I think that's part of
what appealed to me that I loved law
school actually that may have been my
first clue I wasn't fit out fit to be a
lawyer because most most of my
classmates in law school I will not
generalize to all other law schools and
all other law lawyers but my classmates
for the most part didn't like law school
they wanted to get out there and be
doing it I thought it was great fun any
other questions
Entertainment Law it's certainly a
possibility as a matter of fact there
was a friend of mine on the circus my
first year who is now an eight who was
also clown who's now an agent in LA or
manager in LA but to do Entertainment
Law I think you want to have to practice
law and I haven't quite found that yet
what will I be doing now oh I don't know
um a few movie companies have have asked
to look at my book
now that doesn't as a practical matter
mean anything because movie companies
are always looking for things I assume
I've got this vision of the office of a
movie executive there's the desk and
there's I don't know whatever fancy
Digos they've got and over here are a
storehouse full of all the projects
they're considering so you know my book
is somewhere you know sixth row from the
back six down ten over on the other hand
if something happens gosh maybe I could
be a consultant I don't know maybe write
another book
maybe direct I love to direct how old am
I
thirty-nine she hit him she did she hit
him yes sir Rogers or something and if
everybody who talks about them has some
quotes from them are there quotes from
Dan Mary Oates and Anne Rice ah you have
hit one of the central difficulties with
the book dan rice from all reports was
amazingly funny you would be laughing
throughout his performance the thing
about comedy though is that it is
immediate Mark Twain you have quotes
because he was a writer now he became a
performer but his stuff was meant to be
read Will Rogers wrote a newspaper
column we know his his quotations from
that that there are a few things but
only moderately means I mean there's the
lo and behold style he talked about a
woman's clothes he
but the political stuff which was
probably the juiciest stuff didn't get
written down he joked once about having
to rush back to the hotel with his
wife's he bought a hat for his wife and
he had to rush back and the ringmaster
said why so I could get there before the
fashion changed but it wasn't that I
mean if we think now of a lot of people
like the Seinfeld show a lot of people
laughed at the Seinfeld show
but if you say Seinfeld then you think
oh yeah yeah I know that so if you say
one of the lines you fill in the gaps or
Robin Williams one of my favorite I
mentioned him again I saw him live just
a few weeks ago he said and I was
rolling on the floor when he said it can
you believe that it was funny at the
time so when you say you had to be there
that's not just an excuse for a bad joke
it's a reminder that comedy really is
immediate dan rice was hilarious
everybody agreed his enemies even agreed
they just didn't like the what he was
making jokes about but no no great lines
it was it's a cloud its smoke its
evanescent and it's gone so do we have
time for one more or one more question
the microphone one more question
pressures on it's got to be good one you
mentioned that wife number one came back
to care for him what happened to life
number three that's kind of a mystery I
have actually I've got more about
Marcela than any of the others because
she wrote letters back to Texas and
saying we are deeply in love I wish you
could come and see what a great guy he
is because she who they didn't think
much of the marriage either but then she
was gone she went back to Texas maybe
for her arthritis a drier climate
nothing in his papers however when she
died about 15 years later she listed
herself as mark
sella rice McLaren Oh McLaren was was
his originally I meant to make it a good
story as Marcella rice so as far as she
was concerned she was still married to
him and she had four other choices she
could have picked so thank you very much
great question David Carlin spent three
years in the circus as a clown and is
author of Dan rice the most famous man
you've never heard of it's published by
public affairs their website is public
affairs books calm